my mom used to always try to get my
attention during the game she wanted me
to see her
and i was always like i can't see no one
past the court
i get this tunnel vision where it's like
anyone on the court is all i see like if
i do a big play
then all of a sudden the whole arena
opens up to me
i'm motivated because i have a drive
internally i want to be the best
i always have this feeling that if i'm
not working someone else is out there
working trying to take my spot and i
can't let that happen so every day i
wake up with a motivation to beat that
person i don't know what his name is but
i know that i
just got to do a little more than him
seeing how hard my parents worked and
my sister sacrificed to give me this
chance i just want to give back and not
only do my family but to my community
just always working trying to be the
best i could be
be the best version of me there's that
switch i think very few players have it
and i think i possess
it for sure you know when you need to
give a little more find that next level
i feel like they hit that switch
there's a lot of unseen ingredients in
my game i have to be gassed up i got to
be prepared
it's always been the same focus it's
about winning every time i step on the
court it's not about individual stats
it's about winning and i'm hoping that
all the experience and with our young
guys garnered this past year and you
have a chance to make a run like the
hawks or the suns you see this year in
the nba playoffs i think one of my
strongest suits defensively is being
able to switch on guards and be able to
guard one through five so i find a lot
of comfort in that i guess try to be as
much like kg as possible he's 6
12 for a reason so he guarded almost
every position so uh
try to do that myself
[Music]
i think me and kg got along really well
because we kind of had the similar
mindsets
one of the things we always talked about
was just having a routine and i was
always such a big routine guy because of
my time playing baseball with the
dominican republic national team
i had learned how important it was for
success so
we just talked so much about building on
the routine and adding little things
that i needed more of you know i found
the things that really worked out for me
and i've been doing the same routine for
years
and i found a lot of success in the
league i know how much work i put in the
drive and determination i have to win
is as strong as it's ever been passing
has been one of my best attributes and
i've always been
a big pass first guy so it's weird that
they see me passing and then thinking
it's like a skill i just developed is
something i've always had i've always
been doing i just
don't think i got enough credit for it i
think the only pre-game ritual that i
got was like when i go out to just shoot
by myself on the court i chew
green gum and then when i go out for the
game when the fans actually see me 20
minutes before tip off it's blue gum
my high school colors was green and then
when i got to kentucky it was blue and
then obviously
i got to the nba and weirdly enough both
colors came together for minnesota it's
blue and green so
i kind of used it as like they remind
myself of my stages in my career
i want the fans to feel as connected to
me as possible it's because of them that
i even have the life that i have so try
to keep them as informed as possible
i think golf is known i love playing
video games i do enjoy watching movies
have some tv shows i do like but i feel
it's pretty simple i'm a simple guy for
all the time i've lived in jersey i've
never been to niagara falls but i'm
adventurous i love learning about new
cultures and i love seeing new places so
you never know we'll see what life has
for me